when I started to start making content I
hired a YouTube agency said hey just so
you know I will follow the system that
you outlined for 10 years before I need
to see an Roi I was like to be clear I
want to make progress I want to see that
our videos are doing better he said I
have never had anyone in my entire life
ever talk to me about a 10-year time
Rising for anything every client I sign
up is like I need to Roi in 90 days or
I'm not going to pay you work if this
doesn't make me money in a month like
I'm out and he's like and it completely
shifted the way that I have approached
my business just seeing how you
approached YouTube and so I'm like of
course it's going to take a while I'm
competing against guys I've been doing
it for 10 years of course they're better
than I am why would I expect to beat
those guys but I'd like to be better and
as long as I have a path towards that
I'm satisfied that's all that people in
my opinion should focus on now if you're
not getting better and you're putting
the real time into the thing then it
means you need somebody to give you
better feedback